alors bonjour à tous quelques points
d'abord avec philippe juvin aujourd'hui
sur les événements de la semaine semaine
très très dense qui montrent que que les
républicains se déploie à la fois sur le
terrain des idées sur le terrain de la
préparation du projet pour 2017 et aussi
dans l'est dans les territoires dans les
territoires de france demain mardi à 17
heures nicolas sarkozy répondra sur
facebook à des questions avec des
français internautes sur le thème de
l'éducation et de l'enseignement
supérieur donc c'est un moment des
changes à 17h sur sur facebook qui est
l'un des moments de préparation de la
journée du lendemain mercredi donc 6
avril où nous avons un temps de travail
des républicains sur l'éducation et
l'enseignement supérieur qui sera
conclue à midi par un discours du
président sarkozy
voyez brique après brique sous
l'impulsion d'eric woerth et isabelle le
callennec le projet des républicains se
construit donc on a ce temps important
sur les questions éducatives mercredi
autre rendez vous qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit demain soir à 18 heures on a le
bureau politique qui sera consacré
notamment un point d'étape sur le texte
d'orientation des républicains vous vous
souvenez que le dernier conseil national
qui avait été le premier conseil
national des républicains avaient été
consacrés à la préparation d'un texte
d'orientation très très fort qui
présente les grands axes de notre
formation politique pour 2017
comme nicolas sarkozy s'y était engagé
ce texte orientation il a été transmis à
chacune des fédérations des républicains
et dans les départements donc les
comités départementaux se sont réunis se
sont prononcés ont souvent d'ailleurs
fait des propositions d'amendements à ce
tag d'augmentation et donc demain au
bureau politique
on aura un point d'étape sur ces
discussions qui ont eu lieu dans les
fédérations départementales sur le texte
d'orientation
mercredi je voulais dix journées travail
sur l'éducation l'enseignement supérieur
vendredi 8 avril
nicolas sarkozy se rendra dans un
département qui n'est pas en ile de
france mais qui n'est pas loin de france
consacré à la thématique de la santé
vendredi 8 avril à spa samedi 9 avril
il réunira ici à 10h30 les nouveaux
adhérents
comme vous le savez on est dynamique
d'adhésion au mouvement qui se confirme
jour après jour semaine après semaine
mois après mois et donc de la sarkozy
souhaite accueillir lui-même les
nouveaux adhérents pour un temps des
changes
ici au siège et puis je vous annonce
aussi en faisant du teasing que mercredi
13 avril président sarkozy se rendra en
inde pour quelques jours à la rencontre
notamment du premier ministre
narendra modi voilà pour les grands axes
de l'agenda maintenant philippe juvin va
vous parler des questions européennes
et puis je reprendrai le micro pour vous
parler de questions nationales merci
guillaume pour la première information
européenne est évidemment une fois une
information capitale puisque hier oxford
et cambridge ont fait match nul sur la
tamise leur compétition annuelle ce qui
est tout à fait nouveau puisque les
hommes ont gagné contre ridge et les
femmes pour oxford
sinon plus sérieusement la première
information concerne la question de
l'immigration bien entendu
vous avez peut-être entendu que le
ministre d'intérieur monsieur cazeneuve
a informé la presse que il avait envoyé
250 policiers et crs pour renforcer les
effectifs de douaniers en grèce à la
demande de frontex
donc nous nous satisfait les sites ont
évidemment de cette décision mais qui
est en réalité une vaste blague si ce
n'était pas tragique parce qu'il ya en
grèce et ce chiffre est important six
mille îles
certes moins de 10% de ces îles sont
habitées mais six mille îles or toutes
ces îles dès lors que quelqu'un met le
pied dessus sont dans schengen
ça signifie que toute personne qui met
le pied sur une de ses 6000 il entre
dans l'espace schengen est évidemment
clairement c'est pas 200 personnes en
plus qui vont régler la question
aujourd'hui frontex à 500 personnes à
son service ce qui est 100 fois moins
que la ville de paris en termes de
fonctionnaires par exemple ce qui vous
montre vraiment qu'on est très loin les
objectifs et nous nous considérons aux
républicains que non seulement il faut
renforcer d'une manière réelle et pas
simplement incantatoire frontex
ce que ne fait pas le gouvernement ce
que ne fait pas non plus l'allemagne et
de grands pays que sont l'allemagne et
la france devraient prendre toute la
mesure de leurs responsabilités
enfin accessoirement je pense qu'il ya
une réflexion à avoir sur les pourtours
hélas périmètre de l'espace schengen
comme vous le savez les républicains
souhaite refonder schengen est une des
pistes de la refondation de schengen
compte tenu de cette information que je
vous donne de l'existence de 6000 gracq
impossible impossible à surveiller tout
qui sont dans l'espace schengen une des
pistes de réflexion et de voir si pour
garder la grèce dans schengen il
faudrait pas à redessiner les frontières
de l'espace schengen en ne gardant que
la grèce continentale dans l'espace
schengen et en excluant les îles
grecques
c'est une piste sur lequel plusieurs
travaillent et qui nous paraît ne paraît
pas inintéressante
deuxième information européenne c'est le
feuilleton 880 cinquième épisode du
feuilleton pnr donc les républicains les
députés les eurodéputés républicains ont
fait une demande officielle au parlement
européen pour que soit inscrit à l'ordre
du jour
prochaine plénière du mois d'avril dans
dix jours au vote en plénière le vote du
pnr et je vous rappelle que le front
national mais en grande difficulté parce
qu'ils s'opposent à cette adoption
quant au parti socialiste français petit
parti certes est parti quand même les
socialistes européens
ils sont dans une extrême ambiguïté avec
une partie qui votent contre une partie
qui votent pour la partie qui votent
pour votre tour d'une manière contrainte
en disant partout qu'il faut voter
contre
donc réellement nous ne sommes pas aidés
dans cette affaire mais l'information
c'est que nous les républicains avons
demandé officiellement d'inscription du
pnr à l'ordre du jour de la prochaine
session de strasbourg deux informations
qui viennent une d'allemagne et une de
grande bretagne qui ont la même
philosophie le chancellerie allemande a
publié la semaine dernière les chiffres
de son prochain budget les allemands en
fait à la différence de nous publie des
budgets triennaux ils ont des
prospectives triennal et pour la
triennale d'ici 2017 2020 le projet de
budget est très clair c'est un budget
qui est à l' équilibre ya pas de dettes
0 dette et à partir de là on voit que le
fossé se creuse avec la france qui
continue à accumuler et d'être que vous
savez et ce fossé s'accentue aussi avec
le deuxième grand partenaire commercial
de la france puisque george osborne qui
est le ministre des finances britannique
a donné une conférence de presse à la
fin de la semaine dernière où il a
annoncé la diminution supplémentaire de
ce qui a rapport à ce qui avait été fait
avant nouvelle diminution de l'impôt sur
les sociétés l'impôt sur les sociétés en
france et 33 à quelques pour cent de
taux dans l'europe la moyenne est de 22%
et les britanniques actuellement sont à
20% revient osbourne vient d'annoncer
qu'ils allaient baisser de 20 à 17 %
l'impôt sur les sociétés donc d'un côté
la france est bloquée à 33%
les britanniques vont se retrouver à 10
7% et les britanniques
en plus de ça on annonçait tout un tas
de mesures très en faveur de la
fiscalité des entreprises en particulier
des abattements sur les impôts locaux en
particulier des crédits d'impôts
nouveaux qui font que d'un côté on voit
l'allemagne bat il est difficile d
des budgets sans déficit et de l'autre
la grande bretagne alors même qu elle
pourrait être frappée par le brésil mais
se donne les conditions pour continuer à
accueillir de plus en plus d'entreprises
en particulier des entreprises qui
pourraient venir sur notre territoire
donc on voit bien la difficulté du fossé
qui se creuse entre la france et ces
deux grands partenaires qui savent
prendre eux les mesures qui sont en fait
adaptée à une situation économique
extrêmement exigeante
je rappelle qu'en grande bretagne on a 5
% de chômage et quand vous entendez dans
le débat que oui c'est 5% de chômage
mais il n'y a pas de salaire minimum etc
accessoirement les britanniques viennent
aussi d'avancer une augmentation de leur
smic ce qui montre bien que le smic
désormais britannique est quasiment à
quelques centimes près à même niveau que
smic français donc l'excusent
traditionnelle qui consiste à dire on
traite moins bien les travailleurs pour
obtenir ces bons résultats économiques
est en fait faux les chiffres sont là
pour le montrer avec un chômage à 5 % et
bientôt un budget qui sera à l'excédent
c'est ce qu'a dit monsieur osbourne
dernières informations avant dernière
information européenne le 11 avril il ya
un conseil agriculture et pêche très
réunion des ministres de l'agriculture
et de la pêche des différents états de
l'union
sur ce sujet nous n'avons pas encore de
l'ordre du jour mais nous avons une
requête à formuler aux républicains à
monsieur le foll sait que stéphane le
foll puisse se libérer pour cette
réunion puisque il a raté 40% des
conseils agriculture depuis maintenant
qu'il est ministre est évidemment dans
ces conditions on ne peut pas aider
l'agriculture française
donc si vous pouviez faire passer le
message les républicains souhaiteraient
que monsieur le vol puisse se faire puis
se libérer pour aller à ce conseil
important pour la défense des intérêts
de l'agriculture française enfin dernier
point il s'agit d'une élection qui
probablement n'est pas passée inaperçue
puisque vous suivez l'activité
européenne ce sont les élections
slovaquie qui n'est pas un pays majeur
de l'union européenne j'en conviens mais
qui est intéressant parce que le premier
ministre socialiste qui s'appelle robert
fico est hissé haut le premier ministre
socialiste a certes gagné les élections
mais d'une manière un peu compliqué
difficile n'a pas de quoi faire une
majorité
il est en train d'envisager de faire une
constituer un gouvernement avec des
ultra nationalistes la partie qu'on
appelle le sns qui n'en partiront et n
ou fascistes
et tout ça n'a pas l'air d'émouvoir en
quoi que ce soit les socialistes
européens puisque monsieur fico fait
partie du même parti politique que les
socialistes français au parlement
européen
voilà sur les la formation européenne et
notre passion en france merci philippe g
5 points à vous vous présentez à évoquer
avec vous point d'actualité de thèmes et
de et de niveaux différents première
premier point au nom des républicains je
veux saluer la pelle très courageux et
très lucide qui a été lancé par
elisabeth badinter contre ce qu'elle
appelle à juste titre l'islamo gauchisme
c'est à dire la complicité d'une
certaine gauche avec l'islamisme
elisabeth badinter est une voix
respectée qui compte dans le débat des
idées en france et elle a eu le courage
la lucidité de dire les choses
oui il y à un islam au gauchisme c'est à
dire des connivences entre une gauche
qui est favorable au fond relativisme
culturel d'une part et d'autre part des
islamistes qui sont favorables au fond à
une immense régression culturelle
régression dont les premières victimes
sont bien évidemment les droits des
femmes et les femmes elles mêmes
nous sommes un parti politique nous
sommes le premier parti de france
nous n'avons pas vocation à appeler
directement ici au boycott des marques
qui font commerce de cette mode
islamistes mais nous pensons que chacun
doit prendre ses responsabilités et que
les consommateurs eux mêmes par leur
choix ont une responsabilité pour
combattre cette régression islamistes
qui menacent les droits
des femmes au fond elisabeth badinter a
lancé un appel à l'insoumission et cet
appel mérite d'être entendue c'était ma
première remarque
deuxième remarque sur un sujet tout à
fait différent les panama peppers
nous sommes attachés profondément
attaché à la liberté de la presse qui
est bien sûr un des fondements de notre
démocratie
donc nous sommes profondément attachés à
la liberté de la presse d'investigation
nous entendons nous écoutons les
éléments transmis par la presse avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention avec une
certaine prudence
aussi nous souhaitons que toute la
lumière soit faite sur ces révélations
nous souhaitons que l'autorité
judiciaire si elle est saisie et
lorsqu'elle sera saisie fasse toute la
lumière sur ces révélations
nous ne sommes bien sûr ici ni des
procureurs ni des avocats mais nous
examinerons avec beaucoup d'attention
tout ce qui permettra de mieux lutter
contre la fraude fiscale
en réalité puisque c'est bien le sujet
de fond qui est posée par ces
révélations
troisième remarque jean jacques urvoas
jean jacques urvoas
hier dans la halle du dimanche s'est
livré un véritable réquisitoire contre
christiane taubira contre la gestion de
christiane taubira mais aussi en réalité
contre les choix judiciaires qui ont été
effectuées par le président de la
république françois hollande et par les
premiers ministres jean marc ayrault et
manuel valls
depuis bientôt quatre ans lorsque le
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
énonce l'état de sinistre dans lequel se
trouve aujourd'hui les juges les
greffiers les personnels pénitentiaires
il livre un véritable réquisitoire
contre le gouvernement auquel il
appartient au lieu de réciter des poèmes
de rené char et de citer mais césar
christiane taubira aurait été bien
inspiré de s'intéresser aux questions
budgétaires
la lucidité dont fait preuve jean
jacques urvoas dans cet entretien doit
maintenant être suivies de faits et donc
nous l'appelons à présenter nous
appelons le gouvernement à présenter un
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui constituerait un véritable plan
d'urgence pour la justice et pour
l'administration pénitentiaire dans le
cadre de cet effort de guerre contre le
terrorisme islamiste
il faut financer l'effort de guerre et
notamment il faut absolument renforcer
le volet judiciaire et pénitentiaire
nous en avons beaucoup parlé ici à cette
tribune nous en avons beaucoup parlé à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
c'est une conviction très forte des
députés des sénateurs républicains
depuis de nombreuses années et nous
constatons donc dans un éclair de
lucidité jean jacques urvoas partage
donc à ses déclarations d'hier le
constat d'extrême urgence qu'il doit
être dressé aujourd'hui et donc il faut
il répondre projet de loi de finances
rectificative
un vrai plan d'urgence pour la justice
et pour la pénitentiaire avec des
instruments très concret on parle là de
greffiers on parle de crédits de
fonctionnement pour les tribunaux de
grande instance
on parle aussi bien sûr de cet effort
absolument indispensable de construction
d'un certain nombre de places de prison
de moyens affectés aux renseignements
pénitentiaire bref un véritable plan
d'urgence qui devra être financée par
des diminutions de dépenses publiques
moins prioritaires
nous avons consacré la semaine dernière
vous le savez une journée de travail à
la question des économies devant être
faite sur les dépenses publiques avec
eric woerth
les républicains ont fait un certain
nombre de propositions très concrètes
genre appellerait une seule la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'état
pour les immigrés en situation
clandestine représenterait une économie
de l'ordre de 800 millions d'euros
une économie qui pourrait avoir un
impact très rapide
si on veut vraiment comme jean jacques
urvoas les nonces répondre à ce besoin
d'urgence de l'autorité judiciaire
l'administration pénitentiaire va
faisons le vraiment en votant dès
maintenant sans attendre des baisses de
crédits sur des dépenses publiques non
prioritaires permettant d'affecter des
moyens à ce plan d'urgence pour la
justice et pour les prisons quatrième
remarque le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
comme vous le savez à l'assemblée
nationale demain commencera l'examen en
seconde lecture du projet de loi de
révision constitutionnelle portant
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
nous nous y sommes opposés en 2003
lorsque christiane taubira la présenter
à l'assemblée nationale et nous nous y
opposerons à nouveau demain c'est la
position des républicains
ici rue de vaugirard c'est aussi bien
sûr la position des républicains rue de
l'université au palais bourbon
je présenterai comme député au nom du
groupe l'est républicain une motion de
rejet du projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle
demain pour une raison de fond nous
pensons que l'indépendance de la justice
se doit être l'impartialité de
l'autorité judiciaire
ce ne doit pas être l'autonomie
contre pouvoir judiciaire la réforme qui
est proposée par le gouvernement ne nous
semble pas respecter les principes de la
vème république et donc avec christian
jacob le président du groupe l'est
républicain et avec tous les députés
républicains notamment les membres de la
commission des lois
georges fenech eric ciotti philippe
houillon et votre serviteur
nous sommes sur une ligne extrêmement
clair qui consiste en effet à combattre
cette révision constitutionnelle pour
des raisons de fond s'y ajoute c'est
vrai des raisons de forme
nous sommes tout à fait lucide sur la
manoeuvre hollande east qui a été
engagée après l'échec absolument
lamentable de la révision
constitutionnelle sur les questions de
nationalité et d'état d'urgence
on voit bien que le président de la
république est désormais complètement
obnubilé par la volonté de réunir un
versailles un congrès permettant enfin
d'obtenir pendant son quinquennat
une révision constitutionnelle mais la
constitution ça n'est pas un tract du
parti socialiste la constitution ça
n'est pas non plus l'instrument d'une
précampagne présidentielle celle de
monsieur hollande la constitution c'est
la loi fondamentale c'est sérieux donc
nous ne voyons aucune raison ni de fonds
ni de forme pour donner notre accord à
cette révision constitutionnelle sur le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
cinquième et dernière remarque avant si
vous le souhaitez avec philippe lui vint
nous répondu à vos questions
le 8 avril ce sera l'anniversaire des
deux ans de manuel valls à matignon plus
exactement l'anniversaire de son
discours de politique générale à
l'assemblée nationale il avait dans son
discours
fait référence à pierre mendès-france en
évoquant au fond l'exigence d'action
l'exigence de vérité l'exigence de
résultat la vérité c'est que après deux
ans manuel valls n'a pas obtenu de
résultats
lorsqu'il déclare hier dans le jdd qu'
on ne gagne pas sur un bilan on le
comprend parce que de bilan il n'en a
pas ou plus exactement il a un passif
explosion du chômage dérive des finances
publiques
ko migratoire insécurité galopante
le bilan de ces deux années de manuel
valls à matignon est d'abord est d'abord
un passif
chaque jour qui passe montre que ce
gouvernement se condamnent à une sorte
d' immobilisme et de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs nous serons évidemment très
attentif aux débats qui vont s'ouvrir
dès cet après-midi en commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée sur la
loi une connerie
madame elle comme riz sera auditionné
cet après midi nous sommes convaincus
qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de majorité
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale pour
réforme est vraiment le marché du
travail et donc l'exigence qui avait été
celle de manuel valls en 2014
c'est en réalité fracasser sur
l'incapacité de sa majorité à dégager
une ligne réformatrice et il est
désormais donc engoncé dans un
immobilisme qui fait perdre beaucoup de
temps à la france voilà pour ces cinq
points d'introduction complétant le
panel européen que philippe dugoin
allant de cambridge jusqu'à la slovaquie
en passant par la grèce vous a présenté